crache dedans quasiment donc voilà bon
on est en direct
sur les différentes écoles qu'il y a
autour des micros on vient d'entendre
Sandrine Rousseau qui justement dit que
la croissance finalement pose un
problème écologique est-ce que c'est
votre point de vue
ce qui est sûr c'est que les problèmes
d'environnement que nous avons
aujourd'hui sont des conséquences de la
mise en route de flux physique de plus
en plus important qui ont été ceux d'une
activité économique de plus en plus
importante qu'est-ce que c'est que
l'activité économique quand on regarde
depuis la révolution industrielle c'est
produire en quantité croissante d'étapes
des chaises des voitures des maisons des
appareils des pistolets à eau et des
t-shirts et à chaque fois qu'on fait ça
on prend dans l'environnement des
ressources on les transforme et on
obtient à la fois le produit de la
transformation qui nous intéresse la
maison le t-shirt etc et des
sous-produits indésirables qui nous
intéressent pas du tout et qui s'appelle
la pollution et globalement plus on
transforme c'est-à-dire plus on a une
activité productive importante plus on
pollue plus on rejette de substances
dans l'air dans l'eau dans le sol etc
donc la croissance économique c'est la
croissance de la production et donc
c'est la croissance des rejets
globalement c'est tout à fait le cas si
on regarde en particulier le rejet
principal qui occupe mon activité
professionnelle de façon centrale
c'est-à-dire la question des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
elles ont accompagné depuis un siècle et
demi
l'augmentation de la taille de
l'économie de façon parfaitement
corrélée alors on va y revenir justement
puisque on entendait Sandrine Rousseau
parler de la réforme des retraites
êtes-vous de ceux qui pensent que le
débat sur les retraites
occulte les vrais enjeux et en
particulier les enjeux liés aux
thématiques qui vous sont chères le
climat le réchauffement climatique alors
c'est amusant parce que coïncidence du
calendrier j'ai vu passer hier une
tribune de Jacques Attali dans Les Echos
alors je ne suis pas toujours d'accord
avec ce que raconte Jacques Attali mais
là en l'occurrence j'ai trouvé qu'il
posait une question qui était drôlement
bien sentie
nous parlant de la réforme des retraites
il a titré sa tribune mais que diable
allait-il faire dans cette galère donc
en gros il posait la question en disant
pourquoi ça et pourquoi maintenant et je
me pose exactement les deux mêmes
questions pourquoi ce sujet et pourquoi
maintenant il me semble qu'il y avait ça
vous semble un congru alors il y avait
aucune urgence à faire maintenant plutôt
que l'année prochaine ou dans deux ans
d'accord là où je suis parfaitement en
phase avec les gens qui disent on a un
tout petit sujet avec la croissance
c'est que la les prévisions de
croissance sont absolument centrales
dans les projections qu'on peut faire
sur l'équilibre entre retraite et actif
or les projections de croissance du
Conseil d'orientation des retraites ne
se réaliseront pas elles se réaliseront
pas parce que ça fait déjà maintenant
plus de 10 ans que l'Europe n'est plus
en vrai croissance d'accord on a une
croissance qui est un peu fictive qui
est bon qu'est-ce qui vous permet de
dire que la croissance est fictive alors
j'y répondrai après je laisse la
question en suspense
c'est une question qu'on aborde assez
souvent ici donc j'ai reviendrai après
en fait la production vraie de l'Europe
depuis plus de 10 ans elle est en
décroissance alors qu'est-ce que
j'appelle la production vraie par
exemple la quantité de mètre carré qu'on
construit ça c'est physique par exemple
la quantité de tonnes qu'on charge dans
les camions ça c'est de la production
physique et bien quand vous regardez la
quantité de tonnes qu'on charge dans les
camions ça fait depuis 2007 en tendance
à diminue donc ça veut dire que en
tendance l'Europe produit de moins en
moins de bien les transports de moins en
moins de bien physique mes fameux Top
Chef t-shirts etc tout ça en tonnage
donc en quantité physique ça baisse
depuis 15 ans et le fait que le PIB
facialement augmente il est lié à un
certain nombre de conventions qui sont
qui ont dit à cette augmentation
mécanique mais qui correspondent pas à
une augmentation des biens et des
services dont la population bénéficie
vraiment par exemple quand la valeur de
l'immobilier augmente les commissions
des agences immobilières augmentent ça
fait pas augmenter le nombre de mètres
carrés et ça c'est pas des flatté quand
vous faites le calcul du PIB la quantité
de crédit immobilier des banques
augmentent ça c'est pareil c'est pas
déflater donc la le produit net bancaire
augmente alors que vous avez pas plus de
mètres carrés qui font l'objet de
transaction augmentation voilà quand
vous avez la valeur des actions qui
augmente ou le ou la valeur des œuvres
d'art qui augmente vous avez un certain
nombre d'intermédiaires qui grâce à ça
gagne plus d'argent c'est pareil c'est
pas c'est pas corriger
et donc si je dis on regarde ce que les
gens ont vraiment à consommer en fait
vous vous rendez compte que depuis 15
ans il y a plus de croissance et il y a
même une érosion légère et ça se traduit
même en termes strictement monétaire
pour les ménages puisque vous savez
probablement que le revenu disponible
des ménages en France diminue depuis
la croissance elle est plutôt elle est
plutôt
spatiale est une croissance spéculative
c'est ce que vous attendez il y aura de
la croissance peut-être pas bon et mon
pari c'est que on sera plutôt
malheureusement du coup heureusement
j'en sais rien du côté peut-être pas bon
or le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites dans les trajectoires qu'ils
trace pour l'avenir ils se balade
quelque part entre 0,7 % et quasiment 2%
de croissance du PIB par an à l'avenir
donc ça suppose qu'il y aura pas de
covid pas de crème et pas de changement
climatique et pas de pénurie sur les
matériaux et pas de pénuries de pétrole
et pas de de etc tout ça me paraît
extrêmement discutable alors pourquoi
quel est le lien avec la réforme
actuelle le lien c'est qu'à partir du
moment où les hypothèses pour l'avenir
sont gentiment farfelus
on est certain oui on est certain qu'il
va falloir y revenir d'accord on est
certain qu'il va falloir y revenir
puisque la réforme qu'on est en train de
faire en ce moment se base sur des
hypothèses qui ne se réaliseront pas à
partir du moment où vous êtes certain
que vous allez devoir y revenir quelle
est l'urgence de faire ça maintenant
plutôt que l'année prochaine de ce que
ce sera peut-être plus dur après ce que
s'il va falloir y revenir 16h qui va
falloir faire une réforme encore plus
radicale après faut pas étaler les
réformes je ne sais pas du diable je ne
sais pas parce que d'ici là il y a plein
d'inflation qui sera passée il suffit
peut-être d'enterrer l'inflation vous
savez donc je sais pas je sais pas bon
donc il y avait pas d'urgence à faire
cette réforme à mon avis en début de
mandat alors que par contre il y a des
inconvénients absolument évident à
l'avoir fait c'est que Macron qui est
sur un deuxième mandat non rééligible
c'était l'occasion de mettre en oeuvre
des grandes ambitions très utiles au
pays et qui est des grands projets de
société quelque part pour lesquels on
aurait les bénéfices après le terme du
mandat bon là c'est clair que le sujet
des retraites tombe dans cette asymétrie
temporelle c'est à dire que il faut
souffrir maintenant pour avoir le
bénéfice plus tard quelque part
mais c'est pas un grand projet de
société c'est là c'est de l'intendance
s'occuper des retraites et donc il a
raté l'occasion en début de mandat de
faire quelque chose qui aurait eu du
souffle en rassemblant tout le monde et
une fois que il a commencé par crisper
le pays en divisant en deux sur quelque
chose qui est un problème d'intendance
important mais ça reste un problème
d'intendance il a il a quelque part il
s'est mis en position de faiblesse pour
derrière faire un grand projet egolien
d'ambition pour le pays voilà donc je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec avec
Attali quand il dit mais qu'est-ce qui
lui a pris de commencer par ça je pense
effectivement qu'est-ce qui lui a pris
de commencer par ça
puisque vous parliez de d'inflation tout
à l'heure
on devait se parler en janvier et à
l'époque il y avait des restaurateurs
qui ce qui était contraintes baisser
leur rideau des boules boulangers
obligés de mettre la clé sous la porte
et des entreprises forcées de stopper
leur production est-ce que tout ça
c'était à cause justement des explosion
des l'électricité est-ce que on est
entré enfin dans l'ère de la sobriété
que vous appelez de vos vœux alors non
parce que la sobriété on est entré dans
l'air de la pauvreté mais pas dans l'air
de la sobriété je m'explique dans
maintenant que la nature à moi les
manières d'économiser de l'énergie je
les décompose en trois morceaux il y a
un morceau qui s'appelle l'efficacité
donc l'efficacité je vais prendre le
boulanger il vous fournit le même pain
et il l'a cuit à la même température
mais son four a demandé moins
d'électricité pour cuire le pain il est
plus efficace il est mieux isolé etc
d'accord ça c'est de l'efficacité
la deuxième la deuxième notion c'est la
sobriété donc la sobriété c'est vous
vous privez délibérément d'un produit ou
d'un service pour économiser
la production et les ressources
correspondantes alors je vais pas
prendre l'exemple du pain imaginer que
vous arrêtez de manger du pain c'est
pour un truc qui est très très assimilé
à des excès on va dire de manger du pain
il y a des bas voilà mais
la personne la personne qui a la grosse
voiture de luxe qui est garée juste
devant l'entrée de l'immeuble là d'ici à
débat pour savoir si c'est elle est si
grosse que ça et si elle est Deluxe que
ça elle est tout à fait grosse et de
luxe je ne donnerai pas la marque mais
je vous assure que c'est gros c'est
Deluxe
décide de ne plus utiliser sa voiture et
de prendre un abonnement Vélib
délibérément d'accord ça c'est de la
sobriété bon quand le gilet jaune ne
prend plus sa voiture parce qu'il a pas
les moyens de payer son plein ça c'est
pas de la sobriété c'est de la pauvreté
d'accord donc la sobriété et la pauvreté
c'est les mêmes gestes physiques je
change de type de mode de vie mais dans
la sobriété je l'ai choisi dans la dans
la pauvreté je l'ai subi donc là
l'exemple que vous me donnez sur le
boulanger c'est quelque chose qui est
subi donc ça rentre pas dans la
catégorie de la sobriété pour moi
est-ce que le facteur prix on le voit
notamment justement avec les questions
de facture d'électricité et ça s'arrête
pas ça continue on le voit est-ce que ça
va faire naturellement le travail de
réduction de consommation énergétique
alors oui mais d'une mauvaise manière
il y a trois façons il y a deux façons
plus exactement d'avoir une contrainte
qui vous impose une baisse de votre
consommation de quelque chose il y a la
contrainte par les prix le prix monte
vous pouvez plus le payer vous en
consommez moins et il y a la contrainte
réglementaire on vous demande par voie
de réglementaire de moins consommer de
quelque chose alors je vais prendre
l'exemple de l'énergie de chauffage
l'énergie de chauffage l'option A c'est
le gaz et le fioul ou alors prix
fortement monté donc vous en consommez
moins
option B on vous dit vous devrez vous
débarrasser de votre chaudière à gaz
pour remplacer ça par un poêle à bois ou
une pompe à chaleur et là vous allez
aussi consommer moins de gaz par la
force des choses
si vous prenez l'option réglementaire
vous avez la possibilité de planifier
quelque chose parce que la
réglementation vous pouvez dire c'est à
telle date c'est à telle vitesse c'est
de telle manière etc ça va bien avec une
planification si vous prenez l'option
prix c'est plus difficile de planifier
parce que si vous augmentez le prix du
gaz vous savez pas trop si le ménage en
face il va garder sa chaudière à gaz et
baisser le thermostat gardez sa
chaudière à gaz et couper le feu le
chauffage dans une pièce sur deux gardez
sa chaudière à gaz remplacer sa
chaudière à gaz par un poil par une
pompe à chaleur par déménager enfin vous
savez pas trop ce qu'il va faire quand
vous êtes dans la réglementation en
général vous savez mieux ce qu'il va
faire parce que vous lui imposez de
faire des choses et donc c'est mieux
pour planifier et notamment pour
planifier la production qui des
alternatives qui va en face
si vous attendez la hausse de prix c'est
quelque chose qui perd sur les deux
tableaux parce que vous avez
l'inconvénient de ne pas avoir planifié
l'alternative puisque la hausse de prix
elle dit pas immédiatement quelle est
l'alternative et en plus vous perdez
l'argent parce que à la différence d'une
hausse de prix qui arrive par la
fiscalité dans les Français ont horreur
comme chacun sait quand la hausse de
prix arrive par la hausse des prix de
marché
globalement c'est un appauvrissement du
pays ça veut dire que on doit acheter
plus cher les hydrocarbures au pays
exportateur donc c'est un transfert net
d'argent de la France vers les autres
pays alors moi je veux bien que les
fonctionnaires français soient les
abrutis qui font n'importe quoi avec
notre argent mais je préfère quand même
donner mon argent à des fonctionnaires
français qui vont le recycler dans le
pays plutôt qu'elles donnaient à des
fonctionnaires russes et saoudiens dont
je suis sûr qu'il ne vaut strictement
rien en faire pour mon pays alors un
certain nombre autre question
d'actualité il y a un certain nombre de
centrales qui ont été à l'arrêt pour
cause de maintenance en particulier
quatre des plus puissants et les plus
récents réacteurs ce sivot près de
Poitiers c'est de choses dans les dans
les Ardennes alors en cause c'était des
fissures qui ont été détectées sur les
tuyaux est-ce que selon vous le maintien
de cet arrêt était nécessaire ou est-ce
que là on n'a pas pêché par extrait de
prudence on aurait pas on aurait pu
passer outre et histoire de passer
l'hiver il revenir après et bien je vous
avoue que je ne suis pas un grand
spécialiste technique de la chose et
j'ai entendu les deux sont de cloche
dans son audition il faut prendre une
décision dans ces cas là c'est en
l'occurrence moi je n'ai pas à prendre
de décision mais dans son audition à
l'Assemblée nationale dans le cadre
d'une commission d'enquête sur la perte
de souveraineté et d'indépendance
énergétique de la France le président de
l'ASN a présenté
à présenter cette décision comme étant
parfaitement nécessaire et tout à fait
assumé par l'ASN nonobstant le fait que
ça privait la France d'une production
électrique importante et que ça a mis
les comptes DDF dans une situation
extrêmement dégradée
et j'ai par ailleurs des
j'ai entendu par des analyses de gens
qui connaissent bien la métallurgie des
de ce genre d'installation qui m'ont dit
on aurait pu attendre les opérations de
maintenance normale pour s'occuper du
problème c'était pas la peine de les
arrêter en urgence donc moi
personnellement je ne sais pas quoi
penser il faudrait que j'y passe de moi
à creuser le truc en détail
je ce que je sais
c'est que à l'avenir il n'est pas exclu
qu'on est de plus en plus souvent à
décider dans des situations dans
lesquelles aucune décision n'est
vraiment très confortable
je vous posez la question là là on a eu
un exemple il y en aura probablement
d'autres à l'avenir
vous préférez toujours vivre à Fukushima
plutôt que de vivre près d'une autoroute
alors si vous voulez en ce qui concerne
mes poumons sans hésiter une seconde oui
bien sûr vous savez que la pollution aux
particules fines tue des dizaines de
milliers de gens chaque année en Europe
des dizaines de milliers de gens chaque
année
Fukushima n'a pas tué une personne à
cause du surplus de rayonnement relâché
dans l'environnement
merci jean-marco ici pour ces premières
réponses il y a une semaine Louis
Gallois était l'invité de cette émission
nous lui avons demandé ce qu'il pensait
d'un mouvement d'étudiants je pose la
question parce que souvent des clients
on le trouve aussi bien Polytechnique
dont vous avez été un étudiant à l'agro
ou bien aux arts et métiers et avec des
ingénieurs qui sont favorables à la
décroissance quand on lui a posé la
question voici ce qui nous a répondu
du côté des écoles d'ingénieurs je leur
dis la décroissance c'est l'augmentation
des inégalités
parce que quand le gâteau est plus petit
c'est plus difficile de le partager
c'est l'impossibilité de financer
l'amélioration des sciences publiques la
santé l'éducation de financer la
transition énergétique je pense que la
décroissance serait une catastrophe puis
en plus donner à un pays comme objectif
de diminuer ça me paraît absolument
aberrant sur le plan même j'allais dire
moral
alors est-ce que la décroissance serait
une catastrophe pour vous et est-ce que
la croissance comme le dit Louis Gallois
est nécessaire pour financer la
transition énergétique alors pour
financer la transition énergétique je ne
sais pas mais Louis aloi a parfaitement
raison de souligner que la croissance a
permis l'augmentation de d'un certain
nombre de choses qui aujourd'hui nous
semble parfaitement sympathique
effectivement la redistribution via
l'impôt et quelque chose qui a fortement
augmenté à cause de la croissance la
croissance nous a effectivement amené
l'enseignement l'hôpital et tout un tas
d'autres choses malheureusement là où je
m'écarte de son analyse c'est que je
crois moi que ça nous plaise ou que ça
nous plaise pas que la décroissance on
va pas y couper parce que ce qui a
permis la croissance mais vous la
souhaitez
c'est même pas le sujet pour moi je
est-ce que je souhaite vieillir non
absolument pas est-ce que je vieillis
oui c'est un fait donc c'est à dire que
la décroissance pour vous semble
inéluctable oui elle est inexorable pour
moi elle est aussi inexorable que le
fait que je vieillisse et aussi
sympathique ou peu sympathique selon la
façon que on va avoir de le gérer mais
je crois que de dire
il ne nous appartient qu'à nous de faire
en sorte que l'avenir soit de la
croissance ou de la décroissance je
pense que malheureusement c'est une
mauvaise manière de voir le problème je
pense que nous allons avoir de la
décroissance des flux physiques de façon
absolument inexorable et donc ça sera
physiquement plus dur de construire un
mètre carré physiquement plus dur de
déplacer une tonne à 100 km/h
physiquement plus dur de faire un mètre
carré de tissu rapidement ça sera
physiquement plus dur et la physiquement
pourquoi parce que
ça devenait de l'énergie qui va être
plus difficile avec de l'énergie et que
l'énergie qu'on le veuille ou qu'on le
veuille pas on va de toute façon en
avoir moins c'est à dire ou bien on le
voudra et on en aura moins pour des
raisons climatiques ou bien même si on
le veut pas on en aura moins quand même
pour des raisons géologiques il y a une
analyse du chiffre Project qui a été
publiée il y a maintenant un an vous
dirigez une association que je préside
qui qui est un sington donc ça produit
des analyses des rapports des
propositions etc et il y a un an on a
publié une analyse très exhaustive des
possibilités d'approvisionnement en
pétrole de l'Europe jusqu'en 2050 alors
en fait le travail qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on a regardé la quantité de pétrole
qui sortirait du sol du sous-sol plus
exactement des 16 premiers fournisseurs
de l'Europe d'ici à 2050 et la réponse
c'est que la production des 16 premiers
fournisseurs de l'Europe qui sont aussi
les 16 premiers producteurs mondiaux
sauf le Brésil et le Canada serait
divisé par deux d'ici à 2050 ce qui veut
dire que leurs exportations vers
l'Europe puisqu'ils vont d'abord servir
leur population d'investicains ce va
être divisé par n'importe quoi entre 2
et 20 donc de toute façon même si on
veut pas des hydrocarbures on va en
avoir considérablement moins et il va
bien falloir qu'on s'organise en
conséquence ça refait le lien avec ce
que je disais tout à l'heure sur notre
cher président et ses retraites il me
semble que d'organiser le pays en
fonction de ce que je viens de dire et
dans un deuxième temps de savoir comment
est-ce qu'on organise les retraites dans
ce truc d'ensemble c'était mettre le
problème dans le bon ordre
les problèmes dans le bonheur donc là ce
que je dis simplement c'est que la
décroissance physique la diminution des
flux physiques qui structure l'économie
on ne va pas y couper et donc la bonne
question c'est comment est-ce qu'on
s'organise en conséquence et le
mouvement des jeunes ingénieurs
aujourd'hui dans les dans les écoles je
ne sais pas tant s'il est de souhaiter
la misère du monde ou de souhaiter qu'on
prenne acte des réalités du monde et que
enfin on fasse des efforts pour faire en
sorte de gérer le monde tel qu'il va
être et non pas de tel qu'on aimerait
qu'il soit est-ce que la
démondialisation pourrait justement
conduire à une sobriété dans un certain
nombre de domaines notamment dans celui
de l'alimentation qui vous est cher
aujourd'hui on a du bœuf agent argentin
du mouton Zélande néo-zélandais on
voyage là pour le coup il faudrait
l'organiser alors d'abord la
démondialisation elle est déjà un tout
petit peu en route depuis 2008 la part
du commerce international dans le PIB a
déjà perdu alors je vais vous dire un
truc de mémoire elle a déjà dû perdre
10%. c'est à dire que en 1970 sauf
erreur de ma part les échanges
internationaux représentaient 25% du PIB
mondial c'est monté jusqu'à 60% du PIB
mondial en 2008 qui a été le maximum
historique et depuis il me semble que
c'est redescendu à 50
il se trouve que les échos ont publié un
graphique là-dessus pas plus tard
qu'hier bon je suis désolé de citer un
concurrent
et donc le donc la démondialisation elle
est déjà à petite vitesse un peu en
route en ce qui concerne l'agriculture
il se passe que vous savez des exemples
que vous avez cité il se trouve que la
France est quand même plutôt du bon côté
de la barrière au sens où on a un grand
territoire on a beaucoup de surfaces
cultivables et aujourd'hui si on importe
tous les produits que vous avez cités on
importe de plus en plus de poulet à
étrangers on apporte de plus en plus de
buffs étrangers on apporte etc alors bon
on fait pas pousser beaucoup d'enches
chez nous mais il y a quand même
beaucoup de choses que on peut faire
pousser chez nous c'est plutôt dû à des
structures de marché plutôt qu'à
l'impossibilité physique de faire tout
ce qu'on pourrait faire chez nous donc
ça c'est quelque chose qui s'organise
mais ça c'est un sujet de comment dire
de cadre global il se trouve que
l'Europe s'est dotée d'un cadre global
sur l'agriculture qui à mon avis n'est
pas adapté aux défis que nous allons
avoir pour l'avenir et c'est un problème
qui doit se traiter au niveau Européen
puisque c'est c'est à l'Europe que nous
avons confié la compétence en la matière
il nous reste peu de temps Jean-Marc
janvier jean-clau ici qu'est-ce qui vous
aurait vu le plus un climatoceptique ou
un anti-nucléaire
un indifférent à la question
m'ennuie encore plus c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui je suis beaucoup plus
inquiet de l'existence d'une classe
politique et de d'une classe dirigeante
économique qui n'a pas l'air de réaliser
dans quel monde on va vivre que d'un
anti-nucléaire ou d'un climato-sceptique
est-ce que vous demandez toujours au
gouvernement de vous accorder trois
heures pour une explication
20h oui 20h oui
est-ce que vous êtes capable de faire un
prix à une heure comme vous l'avez fait
est-ce que vous devenez expert comptable
en 30 minutes non donc à partir du
moment où il y a qu'un sujet vraiment
important sur qui est vraiment
structurant j'insiste pour l'avenir du
pays il me semble que ça vaut bien trois
heures que répondez-vous à ceux qui
pensent que le renouvelable est plus sûr
que le nucléaire que c'est faux
vous avez des alors ça dépend ce qu'on
appelle sur quel plan ça dépend sur quel
plan sur le plan sanitaire c'est inexact
vous avez des analyses enfin des travaux
de médecins qui ont été faits qui
donnent le nombre de morts par gigawater
ou mégawattheure ou terawattheure des
diverses sources de production
électrique les journalistes au berger
est venu sur plateau et elle nous a dit
que les éoliennes sont le prochain
scandale sanitaire alors je ne sais pas
si c'est le prochain scandale sanitaire
mais en tout cas ce que je sais c'est
que si vous mettez dans les
renouvelables les barrages ils ont
beaucoup plus tué avec les centrales
nucléaires beaucoup et même sans mettre
les barrages les autres vous avez des
accidents de mines vous avez parce que
il faut les métaux pour faire les
éoliennes et les panneaux solaires et en
fait si vous comptez ce genre de truc
vous vous rendez compte que c'est
kif-kif avec le nucléaire la raison pour
laquelle on a fermé Fessenheim c'est
pour montrer à EDF qui est le chef c'est
ce que c'est dites-vous à nos confrères
de Marianne ce que vous a confié le
délégué interministériel à la fermeture
de Fessenheim Francis roll Tanguy vous
confirmez qu'il vous a bien dit ça oui
c'était pour montrer à Ed qui était le
chef et pas pour les questions
environnementale alors c'était peut-être
aussi pour des questions
environnementales invoquées je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas je vous confirme
que j'ai bien entendu ça dans le bureau
de Monsieur rotang Jean-Marc Jancovici
le monde sans fin avec Christophe
Christophe Blain c'est aux éditions
Dargo il n'y a aucun des ratum de
l'éditeur je tiens à le préciser c'est
absolument passionnant ça vaut son prix
et c'est c'est vraiment captivant on ne
le quitte pas ça pose des problèmes
sociaux dans son entourage parce que
vous passez votre week-end avec la avec
la BD mais ça vaut le coup c'est donc
aux éditions d'Argo merci beaucoup
Jean-Marc Jancovici d'être venu ici dans
les studios du Figaro vous reviendrez
nous voir peut-être j'espère merci
beaucoup
on se retrouve point de vue pour
aujourd'hui c'est fini rendez-vous
demain même heure même endroit avec
Alban Barthélémy et vous avez le
prochain live sur le Figaro à 20h avec
le club Le Figaro international et
Philippe jelly bonne soirée sur le site
du Figaro